so our once booming economy now has
taken a major hit due to this nationwide
lockdowns all over the country although
states are now reopening american lives
businesses
placed on hold for months new york city
mayor comrade bill de blasio now
pleading for
federal assistance nine billion dollars
worth
okay now he also spends money on illegal
immigrants
and all sorts of wasted money 900
billion million dollars that a program
he and his wife were involved in that
nobody can figure out
we americans cannot afford to bail out
blue state mayors and governors
like in new york new jersey california
michigan
illinois for their outrageous spending
remember cuomo
wasted billions of dollars like a light
bulb factory
and oh yeah a microchip
and a solar factory now if you ask me
the best stimulus package
americans reopen their doors our
businesses let the economy begin to heal
and we learned a lot of lessons we now
should implement them my next guest has
some different ideas
is the owner of the mavericks the
dallas mavericks he's proposing a use it
or lose it
debit card program to boost consumer
confidence stimulate the economy
mark good to see you again thanks for
coming back hey thanks for having me
back on sean let me say real quickly
your math segment was incredible
thank you so much for doing that the
truth is the truth mark
you know that's it and this is one thing
the country is agreeing on there's
nobody disagreeing on what happened
um i i i think i might actually want
sports more than you i know amer we all
want to return
uh uh well you have more of a financial
but you're a billionaire i'm not a
billionaire
the but the reason is i think americans
are craving
normalcy we learned lessons if we take
care of the elderly
like your governor did babbitt or
desantis did
they did really really well protecting
the most vulnerable they didn't in new
york new jersey
michigan or pennsylvania stupid
decisions they put covert 19 patients in
nursing homes you're shaking your head
dumb p that was a third of all the
deaths
look no one everybody made imperfect
decisions with imperfect information
i'm not saying new york did it right
they certainly made mistakes but so did
everybody look at small towns
in texas and other places that have meat
processing plants
where uh 20 of the population is now
stricken with covid
i mean it's just hard to deal in those
circumstances and so
i mean i it's hard to cast blame in that
but i understand
and predictions were wrong we can all
agree on that but
one thing that always remains consistent
is protect the elderly
and they put covert patients in places
that we're telling them we can't handle
this
so here's my here's what i think we
learned protect the elderly we also
i'm in the epicenter of this every every
week i go to the store i see the same
people cashiers guys stocking the
shelves they all wore masks
nobody at my these local stores got sick
masks are working
i can't argue with that at all at all
sean and you did a great job
sending that message that people need to
protect not just themselves
but the people around them and that's a
great reason to wear a mask
mom and dad grandma and grandpa all
right i looked at your plan
i i like the idea i like ideas i don't
care where the idea
comes from i want ideas i want our
stadiums fall um
and you said okay i'll lose it or or use
it or lose a debit card
right and what up the thousand twelve
hundred dollars you have a certain
period of time
stimulate the economy right the problem
is we spent
three trillion already three trillion
dollars for another
four trillion in loan guarantees the
country can't afford this we got to
reopen
well i'm not saying we don't reopen but
the question so what's happened now
and i'll even put the hit on the
democrats here when the ppp
program was initiated great plan right
but the key to making it work was
getting stimulus money in the hands of
businesses
immediately and so when the democrats
started over negotiating getting money
for museums and everything that created
a delay
that meant that small businesses had to
lay people off
once small businesses laid people off
that create that really defeated the
purpose of the payroll
protection program that now leaves
businesses small businesses in a state
of suspended animation
they they're not open all the way yet
they don't have all the demand back they
can't bring their employees back
68 percent of them are making more money
in unemployment
so what we need to do in order to change
that is to stimulate demand
and the way to stimulate demand is to
give people checks that they
have to spend because the only way
whether a state is open or closed
whether it's 20
25 or 50 of capacity the only way that
they could justify and afford to bring
employees back particularly
after july 31st when the enhanced um
unemployment runs out
is by having demand and so right now
people are saving 14.4 percent
of their income that's the most it's
been in more than 40 years sean
that's the problem we need to solve
people
and getting them to spend that's why
you can have these temperature checked
turnstiles
i'm not trying to discriminate we can
ask older people for the time being stay
away from stadiums
right outdoor stadiums to start you can
give everyone a dallas mavericks mask
a yankees mask of new england patriots
mask we had robert kraft on
and safely open that way
why wouldn't we try that based on the
lessons we learned from the kids that
were stocking the shelves i saw every
week
well one thing you know the temperature
checks don't work because you eat a
couple
you chew up a couple extra strength
tylenol and you defeat those systems
and we still have to understand how we
can do it on scale
it's one thing in a grocery store where
you let one in and you let one
let one out then you let one in it's a
lot harder when you have thousands of
people going into an environment
they have these turnstiles you walk
right through you push people through
immediately
you're right about the tylenol what can
we actually look out for our neighbors
please
if you have a temperature station
all right we want you open we want
stadiums open we can do it safely we'll
figure it out